the uk has had one of the most
successful covid19 vaccine programs
in the whole world
we've already seen the vaccines having a
major impact on infections
but an even bigger impact on
hospitalizations and deaths
and our latest estimates are that
since we began deploying these vaccines
they've probably averted in the region
of 24 million cases
of covert 19 in the uk and averted
around 112 000 deaths so incredibly
successful to date
and remains so
but we also know
that
this pandemic is still active
we are not
past the pandemic we're in an active
phase still
we know that this winter could quite
possibly be bumpy at times
and we know that other respiratory
viruses such as flu and rsv are highly
likely to make their returns
so
with all of that in mind
the name of the game the mantra if you
like
is to stay on top of things
and that is why we asked jcvi
to begin
thinking and framing its thoughts around
the booster program
back in the summer and why the jcvi gave
us some interim advice on the 30th of
june
that set the direction of travel
but at the time
it was too soon to boost people
and there were not enough data to
understand
how when and with what
that might need to occur but it set the
direction of travel and most importantly
it framed
the possibility of a booster program for
nhs england
and for the vaccine task force
who
have been working really incredibly hard
behind the scenes to prepare extensively
for both the supply and the potential
deployment of boosters if that moment
came
so today is the time to clarify that
announcement
to clarify the advice that i can confirm
has now gone to ministers and we await
the response